to The Beatles and Elvis have a meet  yeah we did he was in Hollywood and he  was renting a house while he was doing  movies and we had wanted to meet him for  years he was really massive fans of  Elvis remember we went to this house uh  the four of us all together it was  amazing I mean it was just like a dream  really meeting Elvis we'd fantasized  about him since we were kind of young  teenagers and here he was in the flesh  and the most amazing things beside  actually just meeting him was he had the  first remote television channel changer  that we'd ever seen you know because it  you know it was it was that year when  they they came out and he was just  aiming at the TV and the channels were  changing whoa he is indeed a mighty God  freaking turned the channels without  approaching this television set so we  were very impressed by that